distance ou conformément à la situation
tendue particulièrement tendu et
plusieurs fois par jour et en tout cas
chaque réunion nous sommes en contact de
cette façon en régime de télétravail
puisque les conditions la situation nous
l'imposent en tout cas le résultat de
notre travail doit être ce qu'imposent
les conditions comme je les dis je suis
convaincu que ce mode de télétravail ne
devrait pas avoir d'impact sur la
réalité de notre travail et sur ses
résultats aujourd'hui nous allons
aborder certains points qui sont à
l'ordre du jour
il s'agit évidemment de ce qui est le
plus
urgent et notamment bien évidemment la
situation autour de la pandémie de
coronavirus nous parlerons bien
évidemment aussi des aspects sociaux des
questions sociales et je vous propose
donc de commencer notre réunion par un
mot de mire elle me justine premier
ministre en ces temps difficiles nous
avons à la douma a approuvé le projet de
loi qui prévoyait la mise en oeuvre de
tout d'abord il s'agit du soutien
citoyen les projets à prévoit la
prolongation des allocutions de deux
enfants est aussi aux allocutions des
raisons médicales et nous avons demandé
aux régions de prolonge également les
allocutions sociales y compris il s'agit
des allocutions aux anciens combattants
perçant répéter jusqu'à fin avril
nous avons demandé de prolonger
également les allocutions les
allocations aux familles où il ya des
petits enfants nous avons augmenté le
salaire minimal et nous allons envoyer
22 milliards de roubles à ses fins nous
devons également simplifier la procédure
de faillite pour les personnes morales
nous avons déjà prévu la presse et de
procédure qui permettra à nos gens de
résoudre leurs problèmes liés à
l'endettement
deuxièmement il s'agit de l'aide aux
entreprises
également il s'agit des questions de la
faillite
nous n'allons pas imposer des amendes
pendant une période de plusieurs mois et
aideront les entreprises de résoudre ce
problème d'endettement
la même chose sera fait dans le domaine
des micro entreprises
nous allons également de prévu
l'abaissement des paiements et des
impôts pour ces entreprises
euh si les salaires sont plus élevés que
le salaire minimal en plus il s'agit d
un crédit à il s'agit d'un montant de 2
trillions de roubles
tout d'abord bien sûr les faut soutenir
les secteurs tels que le tourisme le
sport la culture les cinémas et cetera
d'autres entreprises par exemple juste
que le premier
nous avons interdit de le renvoyer les
demandes d'impôts
toutes les entreprises qui travaillent
dans ces secteurs pourront profiter de
ce régime pendant six mois
en plus les entreprises
certains certaines entreprises vont
avoir d'autres soutient par exemple les
entreprises touristiques pour eux nous
avons annulé certaines certains impôts
et comme nous avons déjà dit nous avons
envoyé une lettre chypre pour éviter
double fiscalité et jusqu'à 24 avril les
ministères respectifs doivent réagir et
proposer leurs initiatives pour lutter
contre le courant un virus et pour
prendre ces mesures entre crise le
ministère de la finance a prévu en
milliards et demi et nous allons prendre
de nouvelles mesures
tout d'abord il faut soutenir à les
budgets des régions de la fédération de
russie dans notre budget fédéral il ya
170 11 millions de roubles
deuxièmement il faut soutenir les gens
dans le domaine d'emploi
nous allons proposer de crédit à nos
citoyens et nos entreprises pour
qu'elles puissent payer les salaires à
leurs employés le montant et 150 e
il ya roubles d'autres mesures pour
assurer la stabilité de l'économie le
gouvernement a déjà prolongé les délais
de paiement pour les entreprises et ces
programmes permettront d'en louer en
soutien aux montants devant milliards de
roubles les régions et les municipalités
devront un baisser les impôts pour les
entreprises un échange de mesures
réciproques de la part de ces
entreprises
les mesures pour lutter contre les
coronavirus peuvent être considérés
comme force majeure et dans certains
secteurs les entreprises auront la
possibilité de ne pas payer les amendes
et il sera interdit de l'heure et
privées d'accès à l'électricité d'autres
services nous proposons d'interdire de
bloquer les comptes pour cette période
pour certaines entreprises avec la
participation étatique nous allons
prévoir un régime spécial pour soutenir
la demande alors produit nous allons
prolonger les l'essence les permis pour
ces entreprises et nous proposons
d'interdire les vérifications pendant
cette période les vérifications de ces
entreprises et dans les secteurs qui ont
ce faire le plus nous proposons
d'introduire les mêmes mesures le
gouvernement a informé la liste des
entreprises qui comptent à 650
entreprises est essentielle pour le
système économique de russie et nous
allons
aussi pour voir l'ensemble de mesures de
soutien à ces entreprises
ces entreprises pour vont aux niveaux de
gouvernement avoir le soutien dans le
domaine de prolongation de délai
concernant toutes les questions qui
peuvent peser sur leur budget nous
allons en parler avec la douma et
monsieur poussines nous allons vous
informer de nos mesures heures